thousands of dr fauci's emails have been
obtained through a simple
freedom of information act request and
it turns out
not only were we right about everything
but dr fauci very likely knew that we
were right about everything even though
he said that we weren't
the masks the wuhan institute of
virology
so much more a new york accounting
program prohibits white students from
applying
a serious democrat launches a campaign
against florida governor ron desantis
for 2022 and major league baseball wants
you to know that it is super
duper gay i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from osu
form you later with the four and the
eight that's
a clever and confusing name who says if
you can find an accountant then you
ain't black
former vice president zhao baidin
rewriting it because he is kind of in
the pocket of china and yes
that that accountant line one of the
many one of the many
offensive comments he's made about black
people in his long career
but it won't hurt him at all because of
the way racial politics shakes out
that's just the way it is you got to be
prepared for it
and if you want to be prepared i
strongly recommend you check out ready
wise
now is a better time than ever to be
prepared with long-term nutritional food
options ready-wise has many
options such as emergency meals
freeze-dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient on-the-go nutrition
and new adventure meals for hiking
camping and other outdoor activities
when government resources are strained
it can be days if not weeks
before fresh food is available do not
put yourself in a situation
where you need food during an emergency
prepare today
each meal is a combination of both
dehydrated and freeze dried ingredients
meals are packed into durable long
lasting pouches designed to keep food
fresh
for up to 25 years super easy to use you
just need water the water doesn't even
need to be hot really it's it's
if the last year and a half hasn't
taught you that it's good to be prepared
i don't know what will this week my
listeners can get 10 off at
readywise.com
when entering knowles 10 at checkout or
by calling
855-453-2945 readywise has a 30 day no
questions asked return policy
there is no risk in taking the
initiative to get you and your family
prepared today
that is r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e-com promo code
noles 10 to get 10
off you know i hate to say i told you so
i think we're gonna have to just rename
this show
we were right about everything we were
right about everything part one we
talked about that last week that was
this
great deal of evidence that the experts
were wrong a whole slate of new studies
take them with a grain of salt but the
new studies contradict the old studies
show that the conservatives
seem to have been right your your
uneducated rube conservative uncle
actually was more correct about this
virus than all the geniuses in the lab
coats
well this new treasure trove of dr
fauci's emails
is showing that as well and these emails
it's not as though they were leaked
isn't it it's not
really from some secret source it's not
as though they were declassified it was
just
simple freedom of information act
request let's just go through very
quickly because there's going to be a
ton of
disinformation about this today the
media are going to try to downplay
fauci's emails
vouchy admitting that we were right most
importantly
about the masks now we knew this because
dr fauci said in a tv interview
a year ago a little more than a year ago
do not wear the masks the masks are dumb
they don't work stop wearing the masks
right i'm paraphrasing only slightly and
then he changed his views two seconds
later
and told everyone we had to wear the
masks well here's what fauci wrote
in an email to apparently a friend of
his
um sylvia masks are really for
infected people to prevent them from
spreading
infection to people who are not infected
rather than protecting uninfected people
from acquiring infection the typical
mask you buy in that this is very
important pay attention to the slide
the typical mask you buy in the
drugstore is
not really effective in keeping out
virus
which is small enough to pass through
the material
it might however provide some slight
benefit
in keep out gross droplets if someone
coughs
or sneezes on you i do not recommend
that you wear a mask particularly
since you are going to a very low risk
location your typos i don't really blame
them for the typos people have a lot of
those in emails
but i'm reading verbatim because i don't
want to be accused of spreading
misinformation now we know that fauci
doesn't think the masks really matter
when you're trying to protect yourself
because dr fauci has been caught many
times when he thought the cameras
weren't on him not wearing the mask
notably
he wore the mask when he was in the
baseball stadium dribbling the first
pitch
and he was at least 60 feet away from
anybody at that point
he had the mask on for a big show then
he shows up to the stands with his
friends whom he didn't live with
and he had the mask down he wasn't even
eating he just had the mask down because
he knows that they don't do very much
there is a response to this that the
left is going to push they're going to
say but
if we already knew this michael we knew
the masks are to protect other people
not to protect you right there to
protect people from you right well then
as dr fauci is saying uh only people who
have the
virus should should be wearing the mask
right to protect other people
but the left will say michael what about
asymptomatic spread
so first of all and this is something
else we're learning more and more from
these emails
the cdc says that asymptomatic spread is
unlikely
to contribute to the spread of the virus
the cdc right now
if you go to the cdc's website article
published april 2021 says quote
in conclusion our study suggests that
asymptomatic cases
are unlikely to contribute substantially
to the spread of covid19 covet 19 cases
should be detected and managed early to
quarantine close contact immediately and
prevent pre-symptomatic transmissions
okay but it's unlikely
to contribute to the spread of the virus
dr fauci knows this in his emails as
well
dr fatchi saying yeah that's this is not
really going to be the primary mode
of transmission of the virus okay even
even if it were even if asymptomatic
spread
were a big issue here if dr fauci
thought that were a problem he would
tell this woman to wear her mask
right you see you can't you can't
simultaneously argue
that well michael dr fauci's advice
makes perfect sense
because really you know we're just
talking about protecting people from
from yourself by putting the mask on and
then argue that it was asymptomatic
spread and then
argue that dr fauci knew all of this
when he told this woman not to wear it
because
even if he's telling her not to wear it
because it doesn't matter to protect
herself
surely she should be protecting other
people and so if he really thought this
were effective
even for asymptomatic spread he would
tell her to put it on herself
but he didn't he didn't it was always a
political tool
that's how he reversed himself so
quickly and that's why all of these
other geniuses in the lab coats did too
your rube uneducated uncle
who told you the masks are dumb and also
me and also all of you we were more
correct than all the experts and all the
genius politicians next email
what about the us funding for the
research we were told from the very
beginning there's no way
the federal government dr fought you had
nothing to do with funding
this gain of function research abroad
well we've got an email here
from the niaid principal deputy director
so dr fauci is the
the big honcho over there this guy's the
principal deputy director hugh
oushenklos who responded to an email
from dr fauci
uh dr fatchi had told him who said it's
essential that we speak today you've got
to speak today
about a paper regarding quote
experiments performed before the gain of
function pause
so austin claus writes to fetchy the
paper you sent me says the experiments
were performed before the gain of
function pause but since
have been reviewed and approved by nih
not sure what that means
since emily this other lady there is
sure that no coronavirus work
has gone through the p3 framework she
will try to determine if we have any
distant ties to this work abroad
so a lot of technical jargon there but
you get the point in the last sentence
we're going to try very hard to make
sure that we're not tied to this work
abroad
and then dr fauci is clearly worried
about this too because he responds and
says
it's essential that we speak this am
keep your cell phone on
and then austin kloss later thanks dr
fauci for denying the possibility
that the virus started in the lab well
why is ashton kloss happy that fauci
would deny this possibilities
he's happy that fouchy shuts this down
because then austin claus and fauci
himself
could be held liable for in any way
funding this kind of research
and you know rand paul grilled dr fauci
about this the other day
fauci cleverly tried to deny it but
didn't quite deny it now now
rand paul is is pointing out that the
fact she very likely perjured himself
so there on the question of us funding
of this research we were right
the experts were wrong next email uh how
about
the question of whether or not this
virus was totally just straight from
nature
totally from bats or whether there was
some engineered manufactured component
of it
we were told from the very beginning
there's no way the fouches of the world
say there's no way this was totally from
nature
get it out of your mind that this was in
any way manufactured and everybody with
two brain cells to rub together said you
know it looks like there's a chance
maybe human humans and scientists in
china had something to do with the way
this this virus was beefed up
looks like we're right about that too at
least about the possibility
a researcher wrote to dr fauci and said
quote the unusual features of the virus
make up a really small part of the
genome less than 0.1 percent
so one has to look really closely at all
the sequences to see that some of the
features
potentially look engineered again i'm
not i'm not saying it's
definite and the chinese scientists made
this thing out of whole cloth we're not
saying that at all what we're saying is
that i guess as a scientific matter
but also just as a common sense
political matter if this kind of a virus
is coming out right by this lab that's
working on these
these sorts of viruses and we know that
scientists have been conducting this
kind of research that beefs up natural
viruses
it stands to reason that there's a good
chance that that some of this was
engineered and
this and this scientist is writing this
in to dr fauci
and fauci didn't dismiss it out of hand
he responded and said he looked forward
to a phone call this is something else
you're seeing in a lot of the fouchy
emails a lot of this is call me call me
call me
it's not hey write this out hey spell
this out to me
because we can see what's in writing
never send an email that you don't want
published on the front page of the new
york times
but hey give me a phone call means we
got to talk about this but i don't want
there to be a record
there's another email from dr fauci and
this i think gets to the heart of the
political matter here
okay there was always this bizarre
double standard only bizarre when you
don't realize the standards that the
society is governed under
the marijuana dispensary in los angeles
that's an essential service that's got
to stay open the church
not so much we've got to keep that shut
down why
does it only spreads at churches it
doesn't spread at the marijuana
dispensaries
no it's just that the the liberal
establishment values marijuana
dispensaries
increasingly so as we'll see later on
and it doesn't value churches it
actually
despises churches and wants to keep them
shut down so dr fauci participated in
this too
on thursday march 5th he wrote an email
uh to
an associate of his he said josh you
should counsel the rabbi
to counsel to to cancel the religious
services on and he gives the date which
has been redacted
so march 5th 2020 you've got to tell
this rabbi stop holding his religious
services
but then four days later he said it was
perfectly fine
to hold campaign events and even
to hold some events on cruise ships
why is that the virus doesn't spread at
campaign events but it does it religious
services no
what fauci is saying in his role as a
politician
is that we don't need churches open
frankly we might as well keep them shut
down forever we don't need synagogues
open
but we do need the political religious
rituals of liberalism
and that's the way this goes from the
beginning my big takeaway from this
email
is not the foucy of some super duper
evil mastermind
there's a lot of emails here if you
looked at any of anybody's emails surely
you could find ways to make people look
bad
but i'm i'm really trying here not to
take things out of context i'm trying to
give him as much of the benefit of the
doubt as possible
and what i'm seeing from this email time
and time again is that fouchy
prioritized political considerations
and flacking for his political
associates over
presenting the scientific facts as
clearly as he sees them
and this should stand as no surprise
because dr fauci is not just a scientist
dr fauci is a politician
he works in public health public means
political he gets his
paycheck from the federal government
presidents come and go dr fauci remains
that has been the case from the very
beginning which
also hate to say we told you so we
called it from the top
proven right again i hate it i hate
being so right because politically they
still have
all of the power by the way if you want
to get back a little bit of your power
certain private areas i'd recommend you
check out hymns for hymns.com is all
about
men's wellness do you need help with ed
hair loss or have a cold
are you interested in mental health or
covet 19 home tests
hymns is here for you through hymns you
can get the prescription medication that
treats ed
you get the same active ingredient as
that expensive little pill but without
the expensive price tag
no embarrassing conversations no
expensive appointments just
answer a few questions online about your
medical history and a provider will
confidentially review
if approved your medication is shipped
directly to your door
in discreet packaging and shipping is
free all right i know sometimes guys
don't want to have these conversations
it's a little embarrassing hymns makes
it so easy try hymns today
by starting out with a free online visit
go to for hymns dot com slash
michael mich ael for your free visit
that is for hems.com michael
f-o-r-h-i-m-s
dot com slash michael prescription
products are subject to medical provider
approval and require an online
consultation with medical provider will
determine if a prescription is
appropriate
see website for full details and safety
information remember that is for
hims.com
michael what the fouchy emails show us
is not too much about the science the
capital s
trademark over the e the science changes
it comes and goes
and people who have common sense have
been able to to know certain things
about the coronavirus
epidemic and lockdowns before the
geniuses and the lab coats would admit
it
what we're seeing is that the experts
believe that some things are good
and some things are bad and that's not
exactly a scientific
discovery that's a political and a moral
and religious
stance and consideration and regime
you see this in all sorts of politics in
new york right now i'll give you an
example
there is an accounting program in new
york
for promising students who want to get
better at accounting
so campus reforms ben zeisloft who also
writes for the daily wire
just to put this this report out about
the career opportunities
in the accounting profession program
this is sponsored by the new york state
society
of cpas certified public accountants and
the moynihan scholarship fund
and it is meant for 250 promising high
school students
and if you want to apply to that you can
so long as you're black
or hispanic or asian i think asians are
allowed to apply
not totally sure the one thing i do know
is if you're white you're not allowed to
apply
this is a program designed to give
people a leg up in
accounting but white people are not
permitted to apply
because we have a system of legal racism
in this country
just like the left says there is
systemic racism
and that systemic race the only
legal racism in this country is against
white people and to some degree asian
people
and it's most notable in affirmative
action but you see it in places like
this
as well now this this is hosted by
a bunch of very prominent institutes and
colleges in new york
ithaca college medgar evers college
rochester institute of technology rit
siena college st john's university suny
newpoligo
these are state universities too the
university of buffalo and westchester
community college not too far from where
i grew up
this is your taxpayer dollars
going toward hosting an event that's
being done in association with these
other
institutes that will not permit white
people in
why because it would be we are now
living in a regime that says it's bad to
give
the same opportunities to white people
as there are to black people and
hispanic people and asian people
and that's that and they'll they'll tell
you this if you push them hard enough
they'll say well yeah because
black people have been disadvantaged
where it gets a little strange however
is i do see the argument you say look
certain people came here on the
mayflower certain people came here on
slave ships
and we recognize that there is a sort of
force to history
and because of that we're trying to
right historical wrongs i'm not saying i
agree with that argument but i at least
understand it black people do constitute
the black descendants of slaves
does constitute a sort of special case
in the united states
but what about the immigrants why are we
treating people
who either came here voluntarily or or
descended from people who came here
voluntarily
the same way that we're treating people
who came here or whose ancestors came
here
on slave ships why why are we pretending
that immigrants are oppressed
immigrants chose to come here and they
chose to come here largely to give their
progeny a better life why are we
pretending that they're oppressed
that's insane if you if this is such an
oppressive place don't come here
if the immigrants thought this was a
terribly oppressive place they wouldn't
have come here
but they did so i could almost
understand the argument if you said this
is only for black people it's still
again i'm not saying i agree with it i'm
just saying i understand it
but now we're saying okay and hispanics
too hispanics get a leg up and white
people aren't allowed to apply why they
came here voluntarily
and they're rather their ancestors came
here voluntarily and thousands of them
are coming here voluntarily every single
day
pouring illegally across the border why
are we pretending that america has been
un
so unjust and bigoted toward these
people the people who are
who are begging pleading to come here
and breaking our laws to do it
very often that is not particularly
coherent
unless you're living in a racist regime
that says white people bad other people
good
white people bad to a lesser degree
asian people bad everyone else good
that that is the racial regime that
we're living under and it's no surprise
that people think that race relations
are getting worse and worse there's a
poll out now from rasmussen reports
just came out on tuesday it showed that
people believe that under the biden
administration race relations are
getting worse in the united states
a plurality of people 39 say race
relations are worse
followed by 28 who believe race
relations are better
than another 28 who say that they're
about the same and 5 percent who remain
unsure
as you might not be surprised to hear
that breaks down largely along party
lines
although the fact that the majority of
people or rather the plurality people
say that have gotten worse
shows that it's not purely party lines
republicans are more likely to say
they've worsened 65 percent
to democrats 16 and what you're going to
hear as a response to the survey is well
michael
black people say that race relations
have gotten better and that's only
uh sort of true actually the plurality
of black people surveyed here
36 percent say that race relations are
about the same under joe biden as they
are under donald trump
and 34 say they're better 24 say they're
worse so the plurality are saying
it's about the same which is
is an indictment of joe biden don't
forget joe biden launched his
presidential campaign
the first statements of the first
presidential ad
that he launched during the primaries
began with the lie
that donald trump called white
supremacists and neo-nazis very fine
people in charlottesville that did not
happen
lock that away with the easter bunny and
the tooth fairy it's just not true
but that's what biden began his campaign
on so he's saying donald trump
basically is working for the kkk donald
trump
is an evil white supremacist racist
neo-nazi president so if you elect me
things are going to get better
the very fact that the plurality of
black
respondents to this survey say that they
haven't gotten better
is an indictment of joe biden he's no
worse than that awful neo-nazi whites
he's no better rather than that evil
neo-nazi white supremacist
president donald trump which is
uh i think spreading throughout all of
our political discourse
you see we we use this language of
racism
to describe basically every single issue
and it's not just the left doing it the
right does it as well tucker the other
night on his show
referred to this new vaccine issue the
idea of the vaccine passports that
you're gonna have to prove
depending on where you go that you've
been vaccinated he's referred to this
as medical jim crow take a listen pretty
much
everybody agreed that segregation was
the
worst thing this country ever did
forcing certain categories of citizens
into separate
lesser accommodations barring them from
public places
treating them like lepers or
untouchables that was completely
immoral and wrong we were told that a
lot and most of us strongly agreed
it was wrong so imagine our confusion
today looking out across the country
the very same people literally the very
same who just the other day told us that
segregation was immoral
are now enforcing segregation should we
be surprised probably not but
we still are just this morning the new
york times informed us that unless you
can prove you have taken the injection
that the democratic party demands you
take
you are no longer permitted in bars
comedy clubs even some
dance competitions in the state of new
york you're too dirty
to appear in public you're not welcome
near normal people
medical jim crow has come to america if
we still had water fountains the
unvaccinated would have
separate ones medical jim crow has come
to america oh tucker's being raked over
the coals for this
he's being where he was trending on
twitter they're saying this is such a
ridiculous comparison well maybe it is
is a ridiculous comparison but
tucker was smart to make it i think
tucker was right even to make it
because the only language that we can
use in this country anymore to have any
sort of moral or ethical discourse
is the language of race we used to
possess
a broader framework to do that but
that's been narrowed down i talk about
this in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now for pre-order thanks to
everyone who's pre-ordered by the way
pre-orders are through the roof so if
you want to get yours make sure you
order right now
tucker says there was a time in this
country where we believed that jim crow
was the worst thing that ever happened
in this country
i don't think jim crow was the worst
thing that ever happened in this country
i think it was bad
i'm not saying it was good was jim crow
was the system of racial intimidation in
this country
uh worse than slavery
i think it was worse than slavery was it
worse than killing a million babies a
year
through abortion no i don't think it was
worse that was bad but there are plenty
of bad things
but now we can the only way that we can
talk about bad things is to call them
racist
right we call them white supremacists so
what tucker's saying is okay if that is
the moral language that we have
that if that is the only frame of
reference for people who are
increasingly living in an atrophied
religious and philosophical world
then i'm going to use that to describe
the debt how many times
have the democrats compared something
republicans do to jim crow
they do they say whenever we have a
voter integrity bill they say it's jim
crow
whenever we say that black people can in
fact get id's that's oh it's jim crow
whenever donald trump had a cheese
sandwich oh it's jim crow i don't know
has a jim crow so tucker is realizing
this that that's the only moral language
that we have
and so he's using it because when we
when we atrophy our ability to have
moral discourse
we we this actually ties into the vouchy
thing we hand
all of that decision-making power
over to these unaccountable genius
experts
who it turns out are not particularly
wise or thoughtful themselves ben is
going to be talking about this
on his show today it's called we didn't
start the fire it's going to be terrific
go check that out also you know ben's
got a book coming up
so this is a very important book to
order immediately after you order
speechless controlling words controlling
lines of old now for pre-order
his do i get we can get the ding during
his ad okay that's fine uh
ben's book is called the authoritarian
moment i highly recommend you get it
because that will be my campaign slogan
someday
you can pre-order it at amazon barnes
and noble or any other
major bookseller we'll be right back
with a lot more
every bad thing that that
the left the frankly even to some degree
the right can describes in this country
has got to be brought back to race
because it's the only thing that we can
say is totally
bad ray you hear everything is either
racist
or fascist joy behar showed this the
other day on the view
when she she couldn't quite explain why
she opposes what the republicans are up
to right now
so she said well the reason the thing
they're trying to get after it's not
voter integrity it's not protecting our
rule of law it's not defending a million
babies a year
from being killed through abortion it's
not protecting our second amendment
rights it's not particularly first
it's not just that that they want
fascism
the same people who would keep us from
uh incidents knowing
about incidents like what happened in
tulsa are the same people
who would like to keep us from knowing
what happened exactly
at the capitol insurrection on january 6
2021. i'm looking at you mitch mcconnell
i'm looking at you and lindsey graham
and ted cruz and josh hawley and
marjorie taylor green and all those
people they would like to keep it under
wraps
why why is that you have to ask yourself
that question
you know this is not just an american
problem
this type of taking over the country so
the fascists can rule is happening in a
lot of places
hungary for example victor orban i was
just listening to a very intelligent guy
talk about this
and how victor orban took a democratic
society in hungary
and turned it into a fascist government
the same way that they are trying to do
it here
voter suppression uh stacking the courts
with crony judges
all sorts of things like that just be
aware we are losing our country
victor orban he's the big boogie man
he's the leader of hungary we actually
played him on the show yesterday
victor orban's hungary is much more
democratic than the united states is
right now
i hate to say it it's sad but it's true
what does joy be she doesn't make any
she doesn't make very many specific
accusations because she doesn't have
them she said this
country the republicans are pushing for
fascist rule by
stacking the court with judges but
they're not i know the left is trying to
redefine this term court packing
but the the conservatives are have not
broken a single law we're totally
following the rule of law
in the way that conservatives have
appointed judges the only people who
want to
change the law are the democrats
through court packing which is not
replacing judges who have retired or
died
it's adding more judges to the court
increasing the number of judges
so the thing she's thinks she's accusing
the republicans of doing it's only the
democrats who are doing that
victor orban he's a fascist leader
because why because he was
elected by the people okay
because he really the reason the thing
they hate about orban is that he
he opposes increasing immigration he's
one of the few western leaders that
actually has the spine to stand up
against
mass migration well guess what the
majority of hungarians don't want
more immigration and so he's
following their wishes and reducing
immigration the same thing is true in
the united states the majority of
americans
according to multiple surveys want to
drastically reduce
immigration not just illegal immigration
but legal immigration too
but our leaders refuse to listen to them
sounds to me like
victor orban's hungary is much more
democratic on that very important issue
than the united states is under the
liberal regime
it's fascist what does fascist mean
george orwell
famously described fascism as something
i don't like
right that's that's all fascism really
means anymore there is
a definition of fascism it's a little
vague but but a mussolini
and the philosopher giovanni gentilite
described this in an essay
very little red essay which i do quote
and explain like in my opinion with
speechless controlling risk controlling
mindfulness
so you can find that definition there
but in in common parlance the only
the only meaning of fascism is something
that i don't like everything
has to be compared to to the racism
of america or
to the sort of vague charges of racism
against mussolini or adolf hitler that's
the only way
that we can have a moral framework here
now speaking
uh i mean and this is a bad thing i mean
this is this is why
when you adopt stupid political premises
when you say things like
you can't legislate morality and it's
not just the left who says that it's
also the right that has been tricked
into adopting that language
when you say that you are seeding the
the important sort of discourse
that is required for self-government for
republican politics
when you say things like you do you just
don't make me pay for it you're ceding
that kind of moral discourse when you
say we have a firm separation of church
and state something that has never been
true anywhere in history
you are seeding you're conceding that
kind of language uh
of moral discourse and so then the only
way that you can can actually discuss
the issues that are involved in politics
right
any kind of law all of which refer to
the moral law you
you have to have recourse to these very
shallow things at this point just
talking about
racism now speaking of these fascist
republicans one guy who gets it and
we've been giving him a lot of credit on
this show
is ron desantis he's been doing a really
really great job in florida
now he faces a challenge he's got a
challenge from the agricultural
commissioner
nikki freed who has announced a run
against him she's the i guess the most
prominent democrat right now
in the state of florida and you think
okay wait so ron desantis
best governor in the country is worried
about
the agricultural commissioner no way
except when ron desantis responded to
this yesterday
he came out very very forcefully as
though he views this woman really as
something of a threat
you know nikki freed has done nothing in
office
she does nothing all she does is emote
on social media
virtue signal to small dollar donors in
california
new york she put her face spent millions
of dollars
to put her face on every gas pump across
this
the state purely to boost her own image
at your expense as a taxpayer she's a
lockdown
lobbyist she would have had our kids
locked out of school the whole year
she would have had this business
shuttered for the whole year they would
be out of business if freed were
governor
so she's opposed us at every turn
all the good stuff we've been able to
accomplish for florida she opposes it
and um i've done more i think in my
first week as governor than she just
done in her entire time as agriculture
commissioner
all right coming out very strong against
nicki free in a sort of trumpian way
and we've seen this increasingly from
governor desantis
and which i think is a perfectly smart
strategy donald trump
had had and i think continues to have
the support of the republican party
and so desantis is channeling that but
why is he coming out so strongly against
her who cares this agricultural
commissioner first of all
it is a somewhat powerful office in
florida
um you wouldn't necessarily think it is
but but it is
and because that's that's the one that
the democrats managed to hold on to and
because ron desantis
wants to be the president he wants to be
the nominee in 2024
but he knows that he's going to have a
very difficult time becoming the nominee
in 2024 if he doesn't win re-election in
2022
so ron desantis before he deals with
2024 is gonna have to deal
with a serious election and
that could determine his fate this is
why people have said michael their gop
we've just got all rally around
one candidate right now they've thrown
out a few names of which candidates we
should all rally around
and desantis is certainly one of them i
say look
i think desantis is doing a great job
but there's a long time
between 2021 and 2024. we've got to see
more from people and we've got to make
sure they can go the distance and so
one of the big tests for ron desantis is
going to be the 2022
election and there's there's a
a chance that he he doesn't get it you
know florida is still a swing state it's
it's republican
but it's it could still flip it's up in
the air
and there's this added problem that more
and more people are moving to florida
from california and from new york we did
not move to florida ben moved to florida
right and the rest of our company moved
to tennessee
and a lot of other people are moving to
texas that's pretty much those are the
three places that people are going
they're fleeing the coastal cities that
have an insane tax burden in insane
regulatory state
and insane lockdown rules and they're
going to texas tennessee and california
and the fear
is that they're going to bring their
voting predilections with them now
when i came into tennessee i met a woman
at a store i was just looking at
buying a house and i flew in from
california when we knew the company was
going to move and she said
you're not from here are you i said oh
no i'm not she goes you're from
california aren't you i said i yeah i am
sorry to say i am
she goes well you better not california
my tennessee
and i pointed at her i said listen lady
you you don't need to be worried about
me
you there there are people you got to be
worried about but this is the
the hope and desantis addressed this
directly actually just a couple of weeks
ago desantis
said that uh yes a lot of people moving
in from the coasts
but the kind of people who are moving in
are republicans
so it's interesting with florida like
the media at the beginning of this said
florida's bad
and i think it's because they wanted to
damage trump in florida they wanted to
damage me so they just kept saying it
was bad even though the facts didn't say
like literally last
april they're saying florida's doing
worse than new york new york was like 10
times worse
and so i think what it did is the people
that buy those phony
narratives for these these media they
they probably
aren't coming to florida but most people
see through it but the people that see
through it they think like us and so i
think a lot of these people are coming
i think they're registering as
republicans overwhelming and i also have
come across a lot of people
who quite frankly were democrats the
lockdowns turn them into republicans
because they say i cannot fathom i was
people say i was a democrat because of
education
and i'm in california and they're
locking my kids out of school
i come to florida they're in school
people are free people are happy
so i think this whole process has caused
some people to reevaluate
some of their prior commitments and if
you have a political party that puts the
interests of teachers unions
over the interests of kids being able to
just access an education at all
that tells you all you need to know
about the modern democrat party
well said a very good answer here
and yes this is why they were going
going after him
this is going to be the question the the
the move here
from people leaving the coasts is that
just a typical everybody's going to flee
the regulatory state and the oppressive
taxes and all this sort of stuff
or are you seeing americans split along
party lines are you seeing migration
that is not being even primarily caused
by people's jobs moving
or whether or whatever another dust bowl
or something
or are you seeing migration that is
being caused by
political views i i sort of hope that's
what's going on here
it might be bad for the country in the
long run maybe i'm though i'm not
convinced of that
but in the short run it's really i think
the only chance we've got to hold on to
these swing states and
and crack this this left-wing
establishment in
in any sort of way because there are
there are people by the way
who change their views there are plenty
of people who have moved out who were
say california democrats who just
realized nussolini's reign is horrible
you know
mayor garcetti in los angeles maybe the
worst mayor in the entire
country i think he might be worse than
de blasio in new york and people leaving
and saying you know i used to consider
myself left wing
but you know the crazy lockdown rules
keeping kids out of school
the insane racial caste system the
politics that are explicitly anti-asian
and anti-white
this is this is too much for me i can't
get into this actually there's a woman
at a colorado school board meeting
a local radio host and a a mom
in this district actually a member of
the concerned parent
organization parents united america she
just spoke out at the douglas county
school district
against this issue that's becoming
increasingly prominent
and it's you know from the way you know
ethereal realm of the ivory tower the
but it's it's really now having
a practical effect on kids education and
on our political life
she spoke out against critical race
theory when we look at the gemini group
teaching
which i took time to watch the entire
thing
it is even more disturbing and this
group was hired
by this board because in that training
it talks about oppressors and oppressed
that is damaging to every group of
children first of all
some group of children are thought of as
being shamed for who they are the others
are taught that they are victims
without the ability to further
themselves and to look at the others as
the enemies
we all know the the dr king quote that
has been shared
color of our skin versus the content of
our character he had a dream
this is a nightmare it is a nightmare
for our children and it needs to end now
the training also by the way divides
basically
educators and parents because in the
training it refers to parents as
dissenters we are not dissenters we are
the parents it goes on to say and train
educators
to tell dissenters that this is simply
the way we are going to educate
your children they are our children
we are the ones that have the moral
authority over their education
will not be marginalized of course but
they are being marginalized i mean she
makes an excellent point here but that
that is what's happening this is not
just some kooky theory that was
developed
in the front for school 100 years ago or
rather a derivation of these
of critical theory more broadly that was
developed by the frankfurt school which
by the way i discussed in my opinion
books speeches controlling words
controlling lines which is available now
for pre-order wherever you get your fine
books
but this is having a practical effect
because it's you're not just reading a
book and having an academic discussion
that's never what these theories were
about this is about practical training
to get power to establish a racial caste
system in america which is what's being
done and it's
being done and drilled into the minds of
five-year-olds and people who are even
younger than that
and it's being drilled into people's
minds in the workplace and it's being
drilled into people's minds in the
government institutions it's even being
drilled into people's minds
in the military you've got to fight back
against that or you're going to look up
and realize that your culture
is completely been inverted things
happen gradually and then suddenly and
we're in the suddenly part of that
these people are telling you what they
believe you can read the training
materials
you can you can read the the writings of
these critical theorists
you can read the emails of dr fauci for
goodness sakes you can see
where they're saying yes we're making
political decisions here because we
think this is the kind of society we
should have
not on making a scientific observation
these are the facts no
even think of the 1619 project we're not
saying this is the new fact and here's
the old no the 1619 project
is based on a lie the central lie that
the american revolution was fought to
preserve slavery there's just no
evidence of that whatsoever it's bogus
but what the 1619 project tries to do is
reframe american history what dr
fauci is doing in his public position is
deciding between
what he thinks is better and worse for
society as a political matter
not what is true and false as a
scientific matter but what he thinks is
what people should do and should not do
is a question of
morality that's what the critical
theorists are doing it's what all
education is doing
and the republicans and the
conservatives have thrown up their hands
and said oh well
you know you do you it's all freedom we
can never use political power well
look what happens as a result of that
there is one hope for conservatives
in this crazy culture we're looking and
we're
i mean how many times do we need to say
we were right we were right we were
right
and all the authorities and all the
institutions were wrong and they were
wrong and they were wrong it doesn't
matter
we can we can say we were right until we
were blue in the face they're the ones
with the political power
right they're still able to do it they
lied in many ways about the reasons for
the lockdown they lied about the
efficacy of masks they lied about
the risk of asymptomatic spread they
lied about the risk to young people they
lie they lie they lie they lie
they lie and it doesn't matter they keep
getting away with it why because they
have the political power and they're
willing to use it and we don't
there's one bit of hope for now to fight
back which is
they don't quite have the common sense
they don't they don't and this is
something that
antonio gramsci one of the founders of
this school of radicalism
who i'm not even going to mention what
book
he has discussed at great length in
because i don't want to break my cameras
again on this show but i think look i
think we all know what we're talking
about
antonio gramsci pointed out that
radical revolutions fail because the
kooky crazy leftist theorists
don't have a grasp on the common sense
that the common people the proletariat
the workers of the world
actually it turns out they like their
traditions and their way of life and
their communities
more than they like the radicals insane
theories so the trick is you've got to
take over the common sense
right right now the san francisco giants
baseball team major league baseball team
are going to wear rainbow colored hats
for pride month they're gonna major
league baseball as you know american is
apple pie
america's favorite pastime relatively
conservative
probably the most conservative
professional sport they're going to
dress up their players in pride flags
to celebrate i don't know transing the
kids or something right is that
do you think the fans will like that i
don't think so i say this as a baseball
fan do you think that the players will
like that i don't think so
corporations like that the radicals who
run those institutions like that but i
don't think the majority of people
get all that into it i don't think when
you drive around this country you'll see
a lot of american flags and you'll see
some rainbow flags and you'll see some
blm flags but i think still the majority
of americans don't identify
with those radical leftist symbols so
they're pushing and they're pushing
they're trying
to to create that that sense of
democratic popular support but they i
don't think they really have it yet
raises a lot of questions too what if
you're a muslim baseball player
and you say you know i'm actually not
cool with this stuff
are you are you allowed to not wear the
hat what if you're a jewish baseball
player what if you're a christian
baseball player
what if you hold a different view of
sexual morality
what if you hold a different view of
human nature even you know who we are
what makes us up
no you will be religiously coerced
by the liberal regime
also known as our democracy you know the
left always talks when they
as angelo coudevilla the the great
political theorist writes
when they talk about our democracy
they're usually talking about their
oligarchy
well what about it what about the
players who object to this sort of thing
they are going to be forced
to embrace religious
and sexual views and moral views that
they might not hold
okay i don't think it's totally
effective though
i think they know that the majority of
people don't don't go along with this
stuff
kamala harris showed it the other day
she was giving a speech at the naval
academy
and she made some kind of woke sort of
joke and it just
it just totally flopped with the service
men and women there
and then of course there is climate
change which is a very real threat to
our national security
and i look at you and i know
you are among the experts who will
navigate
and mitigate this threat
and just ask any marine today
would she rather carry 20 pounds of
batteries
or a rolled up solar panel
and i am positive she will tell you a
solar panel
and so would he so it's funny if you
look
if you looked i think she was expecting
that to be a huge applause line
and then she it doesn't happen and then
she kind of spurs in she's like ha ha
and she tries to do it and then you hear
sort of polite
light applause and but if you look at
the images most of the people are
pretty pretty stone-faced out there in
the crowd
if you ask a marine what she would like
to oh you thought i was going to say he
but i said she hm
oh yeah that's right yeah women are much
stronger than men physically right yeah
no that's haha
and so would he uh no no one really
thinks that right this is actually why
the transgender sports issue is is uh so
such a big deal right now
actually by the way if if men and women
really were exactly the same
uh then certainly the the transgender
sports
issue would not be a problem at all and
you wouldn't see these men winning all
of these races
but we all know we all look at the at
the weightlifter the
the strongest female weightlifter in
history who's got giant broad shoulders
and a huge adam's apple and is obviously
a dude
we look at the fastest female runners in
history who
are men you know they're obviously men
and maybe they've mutilated their body
to some degree but they're obviously
men and we say you know i just can't get
past it
why why does this transgender issue
take so much of our political discourse
right now
i hear a lot of people say gosh it's so
crazy that smart people have to spend
all their time debating whether or not
whether men or
women or women or men the reason is
this common sense issue this is a real
stumbling block
because even if people go along with so
many other aspects of the liberal
establishment
this is one that is just staring them in
the face with like big giant muscles
just staring them right
maybe a long hair and a wig or something
but giant muscles and you're saying
no i can't you can't go to your average
person on the street who doesn't have
you know a great education and critical
theory and radical leftism
you can't go to them and say hey that
hulk husky hank over there now known as
helen
is exactly the same as any other woman
and have them
agree with that it's just so obviously
not true so you've got
if you want to take over the common
sense if you want to have have
a real position of political power
you've got to be able to crack even
those most
basic perceptions about the world and so
that that's going to
to take a lot of the political energy if
it didn't matter the left wouldn't be
investing so much time
and energy and money into this matter
they've got to be able to convince you
that your common sense
is unreliable and wrong but guess what
our common sense about this virus about
these lockdowns about
basically every aspect of it we're right
we now know it we've known it for a long
time
and the fouchy emails more or less prove
it
that is something that you can rely on
prudence is a conservative virtue
and i think it's much more reliable than
all these wacky experts but once they
crack that once they crack your ability
to to perceive the world and to use your
common sense
then the revolution will be complete i'm
michael nolan's the michael knowles
she'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the matt wall show we talk about
the things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show